Olaf Scholz sagte alles spricht dafür
dass es die russische Seite war es gibt
formal drei Möglichkeiten das waren die
Ukraine dafür spricht du ziemlich nichts
machbarkeitsfragen sind da sehr deutlich
die die motivationsfragen sowieso dann
ist es die russische Seite oder es war
irgendein Unfall oder wie auch immer
aber da muss man natürlich sehen das war
ein Damm unter der Kontrolle der
russischen Seite und dementsprechend
haben sie dafür die Verantwortung zu
tragen für alles was sie tun und
dementsprechend stimme ich dem
Bundeskanzler sehr sehr zu das ist der
neue Dimension der Kriegsführung alles
spricht dafür dass der krabbel dafür die
Verantwortung